[Music]
with you right no my father passed away
when did that happen just over five
years ago uh
he had ALS and that was real difficult
to witness to like be a part of it in
some ways doesn't happen fast it
happened it takes it took him a while
but it for a long time it was time spent
wondering what's going on because his
body just didn't make sense to him
anymore it he was he had low energy like
the the effects aren't always tangible
they're not visible like you don't see
all the side effects it's hard to
pinpoint exactly what the problem is
essentially ALS is like your body
shutting down
while you're still in it and that was at
the beginning of Silicon Valley the
success of Silicon Valley right when he
passed yeah it was either the first
yeah the first year that we went to the
Emmys I didn't make it because I was
with him and and it and it was I know it
was there there was some there's
something there's something kind of
joyful because that experience meant so
much to me now and all of those people
that I got to work with mean so much to
me that for my dad to kind of be there
at the beginning of it to kind of to
watch that rocket take off and
appreciate it
kind of makes it even that much more
special to me
yeah and in particular I see that Kumail
came in did your podcast he was great he
was my dad loved his character the most
on the show because in our because I
think he had a pretty accurate
perception of it which was that Kumail
is the heart of the show he's you know
and and that might fluctuate a bit but
he always wore his heart on his sleeve
unlike a lot of the other characters who
were kind of being conniving and or or
who were closed off fully closed off
like the character I played and your dad
liked that about him he had that
character it was it was relatable he was
he could connect you can connect with
someone who's open
like that yeah and he just really liked
him and appreciated you know how where
that comedy came from and you know where
that character came from I could see you
get like I could see getting emotional
can I share two stories with you about
my dad I'd love it they're just kind of
two things that I think embody who he
wanted to be all the time but we're all
while he was so he was so sick when he
was his sega's that his legs were as
thin as my arms and I could see when he
came and picked me up at the airport
came to pick me up in a car and he was
driving and his legs were so thin and
frail that it didn't make sense to me
that his body was capable of moving the
car pushing the pedal down but he acted
as if nothing was wrong because it was
really the first time I had seen him
since this had really hit the
acknowledged it did you acknowledge him
well I say yeah I said your dick
probably looks massive
oh yeah What did he say kind of oh we
laughed
yeah absolutely he taught me the sense
of humor so his body is so frail and in
the coming months it got worse and it
became difficult to put his own clothes
on and and things like that and there
was a day when I think he realized that
pretty soon he there was no way he was
really gonna be able to move himself in
the way that he's become accustomed and
so he got up before his wife before my
stepmom and and got in the car she
didn't know what was going on it didn't
make sense like she always kind of helps
him get dressed and stuff at this point
and so she so he just kind of snuck out
got in the car went to Starbucks to get
her coffee because she loves coffee in
the morning and not any knew how much it
kind of means to her and just a simple
thing just a simple gesture of love is
his motive and he gets up and he goes to
Starbucks and they have drive-through
windows other days in Florida and so he
goes to the drive-through orders
and when he gets to the window his arms
are so weak that these two giant cups of
coffee he can only move one at a time
so he like grabs one like the guy hands
him two cups cuff and he's like yeah
yeah just grab the one here put that
down and then grab the other one that
guy's like holy like wow he said
like the looks he got from this guy
we're insane and he was like are you
alright but should you be driving and
then so he brings the coffee home gets
out of the car sets the coffee on and
she wakes up to two cups of coffee which
he had to painstakingly go through so
much effort for and that was probably a
small gesture for him to show i'm as a
huge gesture in some ways but for him to
just show the that he probably didn't
pay enough attention and that's you know
he expressed that to me later but that
really he was he was just like there are
so many times I didn't do the smallest
things that if I could go back knowing
what I know now I would have done so
much more so that's the sad that's a
sense that's a like I mean it's sorry
the whole story but you know it's like
but it's a yeah it's like I could have
done all these things into that in that
moment that was the hardest thing he
could have done and he did or not yeah
that was the hardest thing and he wanted
to do that to just show her some more so
love love love showing as much love as
his body was capable in that experience